I mean, this is one heck of a fish tale.
A 12 year old boy out
fishing with his mom in Florida, hoping
maybe is going to catch a little tuna,
caught a whole lot more.
Talk about a surprise this week.
He reeled in.
Watch this.
A great white shark.
It took about 45 minutes for Campbell
Keenan to reel it in Campbell.
And his mom, Colleen, are with us now.
I mean,
this is probably the last thing,
Campbell, that you're expecting.
How are your arms feeling?
I'm they're hurting right now,
especially my forearms.
I'm sure.
When did you realize what was happening?
About 45 minutes
when we realized there was a shark
right when it hit the rock.
Right when I hit the rod,
it just took off.
So were you scared at
all when you realized it was a shark?
Come on.
I was definitely scared.
Yeah.
I was wondering
if I really want to fight a shark.
Yeah, I think, you know, what?
I think that's a fair question
to have running through your mind,
Colleen, is you're watching this.
You're like, wow, this is great.
Cable's catching something.
Hold on. It's a shark.
I mean, that must have been something.
Yeah, well, right from the beginning,
it was scary
because it was obviously something big
because it was
it was pulling Campbell out of the seat.
So Campbell was attached to the rod,
but he wasn't attached to the seat.
So my friend
Katie and I had to hold Campbell
and make sure he didn't
fly out of the boat.
But then once we realized it was a shark,
it was just.
I mean, that was unbelievable and scary.
Yeah, a little scary.
And as I understand, it,
when you're
on this
boat, like you're going out there,
you're hoping to catch a little tuna.
What did the boat
captain say where they surprised at all
that your son got a great white shark
Yeah.
I mean, it was very chaotic.
If you listen to the videos,
the first mate was just
he was kind of beside himself.
It was his first great white.
And I believe the captain
probably had his problem before.
So lots of lots of yelling
and chaos
and making sure no one got hurt.
Yeah. So.
So, Campbell,
I know you said as it got closer,
then then the sharks swam away.
I mean, when did you
when did it really hit you
that you had caught a great white
little guy?
I mean, it really still hasn't.
But when right
when I got to see the belly of it
because it came up in a
and like catatonic state,
because it was in it,
it was on its belly, the back.
And we saw the White part.
And it
and the captain is like
that is a great white shark.
Do you think the shark was as surprised
as you were? Campbell,
I truly
I think they gave each other
a really good workout
because she was pretty exhausted.
I can't
I just I'm
still trying to wrap my head around it
after watching the videos.
It's just really incredible.
I mean,
what does this mean
for your fishing career, Campbell?
Um,
it's definitely going to inspire me
to do better,
to get better at fishing and like,
try to
catch as many fish as I can
and as many big fish as I can.
I mean, this is a pretty darn big fish.
It's going to be a tough one to follow.
Before I let you go, I'm just curious
have you ever seen the
movie Jaws Campbell
No.
You know.
Yeah. You know what?
I think I'm going to call her.
Yeah.
Your mom is very sick.
The shark was safely released,
and so that was really fun
to get to watch her swim away.
And she was tagged, and Campbell
got to name her grade.
Oh, so what's your name?
Jan. Jan?
Jan?
Jan, we're
going to have to leave it there
because we're out of time,
but it is really great
to have you guys here.
What a story. You have.
I know you've been getting calls
from all over. Campbell calling.
Thank you.